so welcome to the eighth annual adam and
anne amari perry lecture
co-sponsored by the departments of
classics and comparative literature
i'm aisha ramachandran
and on the comp lit end of things it's
my pleasure to welcome you and kick
things off today but before i do that i
want to give a big shout out
to kirk freidenberg chair of classics
who is running around organizing things
here for all of the wonderful
arrangements for today's lecture and
reception that will follow
before we start a couple of practical
matters
let me invite you to take this moment to
turn off your cell phones or at least
silence them
we this lecture is being recorded and
will be online so i just want to give
you a heads up that we hope you'll come
use the mics to ask questions at the end
but you will be
being recorded if that is a concern
and finally there will be a reception
right after this lecture in phelps 401
right across old campus anyone with a
yale id should be able to get into the
building take the elevator to the fourth
floor
if you aren't sure you can get into the
building just tag on to the big group
that i hope will be trundling over after
the lecture and please stay
to celebrate
the lecture and our speaker today
okay
so
supported by generous gifts from
professor gilbert lawal and james m
morris the amarie parry lecturer
remembers the husband and wife bear of
scholars anne amory perry and adam perry
both trained in classical literature and
philology
both interested in wider issues of
literary criticism and the history of
ideas the parries were a formidable team
who ended up teaching at yale where he
became head of classics from 1968 to
1971.
though they died very young their work
had already established them as leaders
in homeric criticism and the study of
other ancient texts particularly
thucydides and virgil
it is in the spirit of their
wide-ranging elegantly written and
exciting groundbreaking scholarship that
the annual amory parry lecture brings to
yale speakers whose work continues in
the traditions to which the parries
belonged
so it is particularly fitting that
today's lecture will be given by david
quint sterling professor of comparative
literature in english at yale
david tells me that he remembers the
parries and their tragic death and his
own astonishingly wide-ranging
scholarship which ranges from homer to
proust via virgil tasso montan
shakespeare cervantes milton and the
arabian knights just to name a few
highlights
emerges from and embodies the
intellectual traditions of the parries
for many of us in this room this is also
a moment of culmination and celebration
to listen to david give the parry
lecture
in both classics in comparative
literature we have learned from his
immense erudition as well as his deeply
precise marginalia on many of our essays
he has been a sometimes terrifying model
for the intellectual generosity and
scholarly rigor of our fields
to introduce david properly
please join me in welcoming alessandro
barcasi professor of classics at new
york university welcome
i shouldn't be here
i don't have a right to speak because
people know you so well
but it's a fine day so i'm just having a
walk around
and i did i noticed the posture of this
event
so i thought
there's really something i want to tell
you before you start
and uh
it's actually about me so
also at the end as you might imagine
because you all know this kind of event
at the end i i will say something like
david quinn to rules
or david quint rocks or david quint is
sick or whatever the language is
in this kind of occasion so my final
sentence will be something like that
david quint rules
but
you know human memory is sedimentary so
let me go back to the very beginning of
my knowledge of david quint
david is now a dear friend of mine but
we don't go very far back
initially david was a presence in pisa
where i was a junior professor of
classics
and you know we were all free floating
between the skull and normally and the
only good coffee shop in pisa cafe salsa
you should try it
many of us were interested in a project
which was about
the rejuvenation of classics
so the idea was basically the classic
was really
always behind the developments of
literary theory and literary criticism
back then in the in the 80s
i mean the very first important paper on
imagery in virgil by bernard knox
came long after
similar studies of shakespeare
the very first influential negative
reading of the anite
by adam perry was later than similar
experiments on milton
and so on
so there was this idea that classics
should try to have more of a dialogue
with literary theory and literary
criticism
and when you start your career it's very
important that you have some kind of
kind of big hope for your field
what i didn't know is that one of the
interesting answers was actually a young
professor of renesan studies who was
walking up and down
with other people i knew and having
coffee
the first thing i noticed about david is
that david you you know how to
to pick your friends and the people you
talk to
you were hanging out with people i i
knew to be brilliant like lena boltsoni
sergio zatti
um you were talking to francesco orlando
the leading light of
peace and literary criticism you were
laughing at the jokes of giambiajo
country
and so on but back then i didn't know
that david had new answers to my to my
quest
and and the big shock after that was the
publication of epic and empire
a book that marks a new step in the
tradition of comparative criticism
because every single chapter is a
protagonist in
discussions of a single author
meaning that the chapter on virgil the
chapter on luke and many others are are
now central to critical discussions of
virgil and lucan
it was a bit of a shock for me because i
was hoping to rejuvenate classics from
the inside out
and now i found out that someone under
the flag of comparative
criticism could achieve so much
in just a single book
after that i have had more attention to
your production
and i came to realize that you are an
authority in
milton
cervantes
montana
tasso
ariasto so every time you enter a field
you change the conversation in that
specialized field
we all say negative negative things
about specialization but it's also true
that
this approach to scholarship has created
very competitive arenas for discussion
and regularly david is a protagonist and
and a leader
so i obviously look forward to what
you're going to say
today
i just want to add that
david is actually a rich person
and also a citizen i was surprised to
learn about that because so many
leading scholars i have met in my career
are not really engaging
reality
as we know it
now david has been active in
reforms and serious changes at yale
he knows a lot about politics
and has a strong sense of
real politic
he was the only the only person the only
friend to tell me that that donald trump
was going to win the 2016 elections
you know in a blue state in academia
people were not
even if they knew it that they would not
say that to me i am reminded that
that david's father was
an important scholar of american history
so there are a number of things that i
know about you now after reading
epic and empire and after
meeting you in pisa
but
the only important thing is that
david quint rocks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can go home now uh
very difficult to follow that
or live up to it
um
thank you sandro
uh i want to thank
aisha ramachandran and kirk freudenberg
for the invitation
to give this lecture in honor of adam
and ann parry and i feel very honored to
speak in their memory
i also want to thank both departments of
classics comparative literature
for offering me this occasion but also
for all the collegiality and friendship
they have given me over my years at yale
uh
i was in recent memory a convener of
this lecture series with christina
krauss
who i wish especially to thank
for team teaching with me on virgil's
aeneid a really precious experience
which is reflected in today's talk
this talk is part of a larger essay
article which is simply too long for a
single talk
i've tried to cut it down to a
manageable 50 to 55 minutes
it is like other work i've published an
attempt at a bird's-eye
of the epic tradition
that is more complicated when it's seen
down on the ground
it's polemical
cast
it's going to be clear from the very
beginning
does epic have a future tense
a now familiar critical idea advanced by
mikhail bakhtin relegates epic to an
archaic closed past and to a fixed
univocal meaning against this straw man
bhaktine defines the novel as dialogical
meaning speaking to the present and open
to the future
it's fine for the novel
it's the kiss of death for epic
and for the most part it's [ __ ]
oh in the written text it's baloney
um
beginning with the odyssey and looking
back on the iliad epic poems look i
look back from a later
moment on their predecessors and models
and in doing so they imagine how a later
moment a future will look back on them
this retrospection projection becomes
more intense as epic moves historically
from the homeric oral archaic world to
first hellenistic and roman epic and
then another millennium later to the
writing of epic poems along classical
models in the renaissance
beginning with the odyssey 2 and then
repeated as a topos and poem after poem
epic presents a scene that creates
distance
temporal and historical upon its heroic
fiction and that breaks out of its past
which was never the absolute
self-contained past wrongly described by
hegelian critics
this particular type scene
is the hospitality and banquet that the
physician king alcinois offers to
odysseus at scaria in books
excuse me 8-13 of the odyssey
and the similar welcome and banquet
modeled on the odyssey episode that dido
gives for aeneas at carthage
in books one and three of the aeneid
to arrive at a scarier or carthage is a
kind of time travel into the future
through a wormhole that opens out of the
epic world
these episodes project a world and
audience foreign to its heroic world
that is also an alternative future or
modernity
the world of its later readers
we readers are to see ourselves invited
to the epic banquet and as part of the
poem's internal addresses
it is assumed that we readers in the
future may or may not share the heroic
ethos of martial epic
ties as it is to in our archaic society
we are asked to measure our own values
and versus that ethos
for better or for worse
the scarier carthage topic contains some
of the following elements
his hosts grants to the wandering hero a
safe harbor at least a harbor that
initially seems to be safe the hero
tells the story of his history and
adventures at a banquet given by his in
his honor
the house already appreciates stories of
the hero the fiation singer demonicus
recounts the fighting at troy
the carthaginians have depicted aeneas
in the scenes of the trojan war on the
temple of juneau
the two heroes weep at these stories
but the hosts have made them into
objects of aesthetic entertainment
the hosts the
visions and phoenicians of carthage
live in a society that appears less
heroic and warlike
but more materially advanced
more scientifically and technologically
developed than the hero's own
the hero was already part of a past that
is half mythical and as odysseus himself
described in his storytelling it's
consigned partly to an underworld and to
a partly a dead past
the hero is in fact invited
to leave his own world
perhaps to get with the living present
and the way of the future
through marriage with the local princess
alcinois offers to wed his daughter
nausicaa to odysseus and dido goes
further she starts an affair with aeneas
and declares herself his wife
the seafaring phasians are wealthy
sophisticates unwar like vaguely
effeminate their queen arete seems to be
their real ruler
they are better at dancing with the ball
than at athletics
sir moses finally speaks of scary as a
kind of utopia and indeed beneath a thin
poetic disguise
faith and society appears to contain
what finley has appeared elsewhere to be
conspicuously absent and excluded from
the noble households of the odyssey
trade on the one hand and the art of
metal working
the two are connected
for metals were the most important
commodities of ancient merchants
the wealth of alcinois and his landed
aristocracy officially depends on the
fabulous fertility of scaria
and one fiatian nobleman insults
odysseus by telling him that he
resembles a merchant seaman a man of
business grasping for profits
but it is the fiations themselves
nausicaa has told odysseus
who have no concern with the bowen
quiver but it's all mass and oars of
ships and the balanced vessels
themselves in which they delight and
crossing the gray sea and that should be
on you this very long handout which
gives you an idea of just how much of
this you have to endure
and indeed the fiations appear to have
magic ships that not only move swift as
thought or as winged creatures but seem
to understand men's thoughts and
purposes and they know all the cities of
men
that is
the fiation ships and their masters have
navigated the entire mediterranean and
they bear more than a passing
resemblance both in their wealth and in
their name
to the despised phoenician traders
gnawers of men's goods who craw who crop
up repeatedly in a disease's lying
stories in the second half of the poem
and also in
his own life story
homer also transfers to scaria the metal
working wonders of the iliad's
hephaestus
outside the palace of alcinois itself
adorned with bronze walls silver columns
and golden doors stand dogs of silver
and gold fashioned by hephaestus to
stand watch over the palace
being themselves immortal in all their
days they are ageless
now it's hard to know whether these dogs
are mere statues like the torch-bearing
young men made of gold inside the palace
or whether they are automata
like those in the shape of young women
who serve in hephaestus's olympian
palace in the iliad in elite 18.
the viation singer demonicus sings two
songs about the trojan war
the second song culminates with the
fighting around the house of diaphobus
the second trojan husband of helen
in between
he tells about her festus straying wife
aphrodite and her lover aries
aries who has won her both with gifts
and with his splendid person
hephaestus traps the couple and in that
so finely wrought as to be invisible
and this song defines excuse me he traps
them in a net that is so fine as to be
invisible
this song defines a thiation subject
matter as opposed to the matter of epic
hephaestus's metallurgical techne
overcoming the god of war himself
one doesn't need to fight a trojan war
over an adulterous wife
nor write an iliad about it
the divine smithy demands repayment of
his epic courtship gifts sorry
and poseidon agrees to make sure that
ares pays the adulterer's damages
these are how such manners are handled
on olympus and in a civilized wealthy
society like that of the fiations
the story anticipates the entrapment of
penelope's suitors minus virtuous
penelope herself
through the craftiness of odysseus in
the odyssey's second half
but in contrast it makes the bloody
ending of the poem feel like something
like a recruit essence
of an atavistic epic violence
it also expressed as an all-too-human
view of the olympian gods
a measure of the skepticism that may
accompany the excuse me the materialist
outlook of the fiations
this smithy hephaestus is their kind of
god
in the aftermath of troy the odyssey
depicts a world that is already post
heroic
measuring the distance of his own early
8th century bce audience from the epic
past
it dramatizes this historical distance
in the fiations who lie in even greater
removed so post-post-heroic
as to be non-heroic
like many utopian fictions they may lie
in an imagined future a readership of
the poem that is yet to come
enter
dido's carthage if scarier registers
what it means for the odyssey to come
after the iliad and its heroic world
the need measures the nearly thousand
years of human civilization and in
particular the rise of rome and of
literature in latin
that separates it from the archaic world
depicted in both homeric epics
it does so by presenting the versions of
scary and the carthage that has just
been founded and which will no be no
more by virgil's day i'm sorry it does
so by presenting its version obscuria in
the carthage that has just been founded
and that will be no more by virgil's day
history's defeated rival to rome
carthage is nonetheless rome's double
the closest image in the poem of the
rich and sophisticated city that the
future rome will be
both are non-greek
and a linguistic as well as a historical
remove from homer
dido and her urbane carthaginians
welcomed the trojan remnants who
straggled to her shores from the heroic
world of troy
but the carthaginians are not part of
that world
and belong to a more civilized future
they provide an enthralled audience for
aeneas's narration of the fall of his
city and subsequent wanderings and so
prefigure a modern cultured readership
in virgil's own rome and beyond
a carthage modeled on scarier and the
fiations however
already carried with it unflattering
connotations from ancient critics of
homer
from within athens of the late fourth
century the reactionary plato objected
to odysseus's praise of the pleasure and
good fellowship the eofrozine of the
fiation banquets
odysseus says it's the most beautiful of
things
he also objected to the song of aries in
aphrodite in particular in his attack on
the immorality of the homeric poems in
the third book of the republic
philip hardy notes the defenders of
homer had to allegorize the body's story
so that venus and mars would embody the
empedoclean cosmogonic principles of
love and strife
as they do with the opening of
lucretius's dehraram natura
and virgin himself apparently refers to
this allegoriesis of venus and mars and
the song of the nymph climbing in the
fourth georgic
classical writers of platonic and
aristocratic leanings pamela gordon has
shown condemned the fiations by
identifying them with vulgar
epicureanism the pursuit of hedonistic
pleasure
the cryptic
phoenician attributes of the phiatians
and the odyssey itself now belong in the
aeneid to real phoenicians
the colonists who have followed dido
from tyre
so it's with the people identified with
despised trade and double dealing
that virgil links the associations with
epicureanism
vulgar and real
that gordon and other critics have
identified in the carthage episode
these include the city's opulence dido's
skepticism about the gods who have
ordered aeneas to leave her
really the gods care about that she says
and the sexual indulgence which attempts
the hero to withdraw from his heroic
mission
here too a female ruler
marks the merchant carthaginians with
effeminacy
in place of demonic's song about aries
and aphrodite daddy's bard dido's bard
yopas
sings a cosmogonic song about the
movement of the stars the origins of men
and beasts rain and lightning
yopus's song is a miniature piece of
natural science
and it pointedly excludes the gods
wealthy materialist godless carthage is
disparaged twin
that has like remus been obliterated by
rome but which seems nonetheless to
prefigure and constitute one side
of the metropolis that rome has become
in virgil's own day
the city that augustus was transforming
into marble
as aeneas watches carthage going up he
sees the foundations being laid for
theater
we are alerted immediately to the drama
of dido that will soon be played out in
the poem with its frequent imitations
and references to greek tragedy
but the theater is also a glaring
anachronism in the heroic world of the
poem a further sign that carthage stands
for a later stage of civilization
urbane scientific disenchanted
a world of high culture capable of
producing the aeneid itself
one would not expect to see a theater in
the backward and poor italy of the
second half of the poem
there too as in the conclusion of the
second part of the odyssey the new
trojan war fought in the italian
boondocks feels regressive compared to
scaria like carthage
this backward feeling is both reinforced
and complicated by virgil separating out
from carthage the hephaestus material
that homer had joined to the fiations in
the odyssey and by his moving it to the
italy of the poem's second half
gold may be everywhere in carthage
but the divine goldsmith under his name
of vulcan his roman name
has taken up residence off the coast of
italy where in book 8 he uses his skill
not to make the luxury of pertinences of
a physia or carthage
but to produce the weapons of rome
the episode of vulcan's casting the
shield of aeneas directly follows an
italian version of dido's earlier
banquet and its storytelling
evander has hosted aeneas at the
religious festival outside palantium and
recounted to him the story of hercules
and the fire monster caicos where dido's
carthaginians are rich and listen to the
post-epic and listen to post-epic
natural philosophy of yopus's song
evander's arcadians are poor and his
story of hercules is pre-epic
part of a deeper mythological past
before the trojan war
hercules fights
primal natural forces
the contrast suggests the violent
primitiveness of italy
italian caicos is in fact the haft beast
half god son of vulcan hephaestus
himself
and he makes a curious double of the
shield embodying roman history to which
the loaf-making of vulcan and venus now
gives birth
vulcan not only returns to making armor
as he had done for achilles
in the iliad he does so ironically
enough at the behest of his wife venus
on behalf of aeneas the offspring of
another of her adulterous affairs
venus seduces her husband with evident
allusions to
democracifiation song about venus and
mars in addition vulcan manufactures the
thunderbolts of jupiter himself
these constitute a conservative answer
to the science of the lucretius or eopus
who sings about the natural origins of
rain and lightning and who would thus
dispel superstition about divine thunder
placed in a fiery cavern beneath the
aeolian isles next to eolis's prison of
the winds described at the opening of
the poem
vulcan's forge is a kind of underworld
but it belongs to and predicts no less
than the riches and sophistication of
carthage rome's modern present that
vulcan depicts on the shield he makes
for aeneas the aegis under which the
hero will literally fight in the second
half of the poem
hephaestian skill produces the superior
weapons themselves technological marvels
that will lead to roman conquest
by splitting the fiation matter of the
odyssey into the respective episodes of
carthage and vulcan's forge
the aeneas projects two versions of the
future rome they coexist as parts of the
same modern city and of the audience to
which the poem is addressed they encode
different readerly attitudes towards its
own epic fiction and towards the role of
the poet himself embodied in vulcan's
artifice
the carthaginian fiation attitude
materialist scientifically enlightenment
skeptical about the gods
appears to supersede the heroic ethos
that dido and her fellow citizens enjoy
hearing about for minis the storyteller
dido offers tunis a substitute for his
martial labors and a peaceable enjoyment
of domesticity and the wealth of a
commercial people
through vulcan virgil may insert rome's
future into the india's epic past
but he also recruits aeneas and epic's
heroic ethos for the military-industrial
complex of the roman state
for the interests of its aristocracy and
its new augustine monarchy a project
that requires the maintenance of a
religious establishment and of religious
fear itself
the ambition and sublimity of virgil's
epic may need such a project as much as
the project needs it
otherwise
its vulcan might find himself reduced to
making toys for eros
as a polonius as hephaestus does in the
argonautica
or
he makes a horse trough
for incalymicus
but it is a devil's bargain as is the
achievement of rome itself
the aeneid evidently does put epic its
archaic warrior heroism and its
old-fashioned religion into the service
of the modern war machine and its pious
warlords
insisting on their continuing relevance
for the present warfare of today may be
infinitely more complex and global
but still war
it's more of the same
it is a reading and an attitude towards
epic that virgil knowingly transmits to
his present and beyond it
and it may be for that reason he wanted
to burn the aeneid
his sympathies may lie with the
carthaginian fiation sensibility that
the indeed censures for its unbelief and
effeminacy and depicts under historical
erasure overcome and obliterated by
roman military success
but that sensibility persists inside the
poem to be recuperated
in part in the poet's own day
more fully perhaps by readers in a
future still to come
now like virgil renaissance poets
inherited epic after a long historical
lapse
they took up the classical genre 1500
years later in their own vernacular
literary languages in an age reshaped by
new mercantile capitalism new global and
astronomical discoveries new
technologies of gunpowder and navigation
new science and new secular attitudes
that accompanied all these developments
renaissance epic poets repeatedly staged
their modern distance from the heroic
world and ethos that they depict
by rewriting versions of the phiatian
carthaginian banquet scene
as virgil does in his depiction of
carthage the renaissance poet can take a
critical even overtly hostile
view towards the majority of his own
world
materialistic and unheroic
what may seem to prevent the possibility
of the heroic in the poet's own present
but the poet also not so secretly
registers in advance over the heroic
past
that allows a hearing for other values
secular scientific peaceable
ariosto and comoys provide contrasting
cases
and iris as orlando friozzo has the most
elaborate of these reworkings of the
fiation episode and therefore i can't
really include it
um i'm going to have to just briefly
summarize it
uh the paladin
uh ronaldo i have summarized on the page
that i've just
put down there
the paladin ronaldo in the 8th century
is hosted in
in mantra
and given a banquet dinner
and then is given a ship to take him
down the po
and as he goes down the po he comes to
what is the the site of of the future
ferrara which is and he where among
other things an island in the the uh in
the po which had been uh turned into a
pleasure garden by the by the estee
aristo's patrons and which is compared
and this is on your handout to uh said
that
nasica and and and al-sinus would not
would
it's even better than anything that they
had which is a tip-off to the the
origins of the episode
at the same time ronaldo hears two
stories of adultery um and about
adulterous wives and husbands in both
cases the wives are seduced by rich by
riches uh into adultery and the second
case is is the it is the wife of a judge
so we've come down into the sphere of
the bourgeoisie
she is seduced by a gold defecating dog
and
he is in turn seduced
by
and
gives up his own body for a splendid
palace um
the manchurian setting allows ariesto
also to
praise the duchess isabella deste the
sister of his for for raising patrons
and um and other female rulers
versions of arete
so this modern world
uh contrast is projected out of the 8th
out of the 8th century and it looks very
much like the modern italian city state
it's
morally compromised as these stories of
adultery
and
suggest and they're of course modeled
on the aries an aphrodite story
originally
but it has its advantages
splendid palaces
filled with renaissance artwork and
patrons for the poet
so if the orlando friozzo
finally catches up to this modern world
at its end
and it this is this is the it is at the
very end of the poem i should have said
as well
the luciades of comoise have been there
almost from their start and never leave
it
after the initial skirmish between vasco
de gama's crew and the inhabitants of
mozambique almost all of the ensuing
episodes of the poem are versions of the
stay of the neus and virgil's carthage
in canto two mercury descends to warren
de gama to flee away from mombasa as he
had warned aeneas to leave dido in the
india
the portuguese make for malindi where
their ambassador first echoes virgil's
ileoneus gedido and then invokes the
example of the hospitality of alcinois
the malindian king is a is a dido
al-sinus figure who welcomes the
portuguese and listens to the gamma for
the next three cantos tell narratives
about portuguese heroism in the past and
about its national wars against islam
against islam and spain and then about
his own relatively uneventful voyage the
storm of book six drives tagama to
calicut much as the storm of book one of
the aeneid drives aeneas to carthage and
calicut too turns out to be a carthage
from which the hero must escape through
the warning of the north african moor
monsaede who is privy to the plots of
the muslim traders against the
portuguese
that is plays the role of mercury
admonishing aeneas to leave dido's city
the island of love of the last two
kantos is introduced to us is still
another carthage venus had once invoked
such a device the poet declares to greet
and kaise's son aeneas in that meadow
where dido's subtlety bought carthage
with a bull's hide
the portuguese enjoy a sexual interlude
there in book nine where they join all
other where they join all other lovers
including adulteresses
who are ensnared in vulcan's net
in the last 10th canto they are
entertained by a siren who sings of
things not known to yopus of carthage
nor to demonicus among the fiations
first a prophecy of future portuguese
wars in victories in asia this is the
demonicus part
then as her place is taken by tethus a
yopus-like lesson in cosmography
which uses as a prop a scale model of
the universe enclosed in a crystal
sphere based on a similar sphere made by
archimedes and celebrated by cicero at
the poet claudium
kamoish conveniently labels all of these
episodes
for the reader to make sure that we know
where we are in the epic tradition and
it seems that we never leave carthage
all the poem alternates between bad
inhospitable carthages that will be
destroyed and good hospitable ones
the luciades thus place almost all of
its narrative present in one or other of
these versions of carthage
scaria the locus of unheroic modernity
and these appear to crowd
conventional martial action into the
past and practically out of de gama's
mission which is at once a failed
attempt to set up a trading pact in
calicut and a successful voyage of
reconnaissance he charts out the sea
route to india knowing that the
portuguese will return with their
warships and establish an indian ocean
empire
for it is the portuguese instead of
their various hosts who are the true
moderns of the poem
which recounts events that were only two
generations removed when kamoish began
writing about them
they have guns and at malindi they give
a demonstration as a supposed
celebration and salute to the sultan
it was like the cyclopes at the smithy
as the firebombs were exploded
these are the new thunderbolts from
vulcan's forge that make ancient warfare
obsolete as the arms made by vulcan in
the aeneid and themselves represented
the modern weaponry that would build
rome's imperial might and would relegate
homeric warfare to a distant heroic past
so portugal the poet announces will be a
new rome but on a much larger global
scale
but portugal's empire will be an empire
of trade and this rome itself may look
more like a carthage
the portuguese possessed the maritime
technology and skills of navigation that
make them the new fiations phoenicians
with magic ships capable of reaching all
destinations
komoy celebrates a portugal that has
transformed the globe into a large
commercial network where beneath the
superficial differences
all ports of call are the same a
carthage that is everywhere starting at
home
the closing stanzas 99
of uh i'm sorry of book night of book
eight of the luciades draw on ariestos
language in kanto 43 of the furiosa to
invade in their own turn against modern
greed and corruption
but where aristo sees his own moneyed
world as possibly saner and more
peaceable than the heroic world of his
poem the soldier kamoish wonders if his
vocation is gone
heroism emptied out or tainted by
mercenary aims in portugal's great
imperial venture
beneath the poem's notorious double time
scheme sorry
not double time scheme
beneath the poem's notorious double
divine machinery of a christian god to
whom
da gama prays and of classical gods who
respond
lies a disenchanted world of all to
human motivation
muslim traitors bribe the catwal the
minister of calicut to prevent dagama
from leaving calicut and to scuttle his
mission
dagama's main aeneas-like act in the
poem michael murran and timothy hampton
have shown is simply to extricate
himself out of this carthage in the nick
of time
an arab fleet from mecca armed with
cannonry of their own
vulcan's thunderbolts as the poem calls
them
is due to arrive on the scene
but de gama has really no place to go
except to another carthage he and his
poet are trapped in their own modernity
so tasso's version of the physician
carthaginian banquet in the jerusalem
in the episode of the magus or sage of
ascalon
who alerted by peter the hermit invites
the crusaders carlo and ubaldo into his
underground dwelling in cato 14.
the basic shape of the toe topos can be
discerned the magus offers them a meal
in his splendid palace which is a
product of untold wealth and a locus of
natural philosophy in an inset narration
he recounts to them the story of armeda
and ronaldo
the next morning he sends them on their
way to rescue ronaldo on the marvelous
ship of fortune which is a version of
the fiation's magical ships
but the pattern is complicated by
tasso's further modeling of the episode
on the descent beneath the earth of
virgil's aristeas in the fourth georgic
on a more recent invitation of that
virgilian episode in fracastoro's short
scientific epic syphilis
the magus lives
it's our on
the magus lives in a at the at this in a
realm of the source of rivers and lower
down of living silver mercury
and sparkling gemstones that fill his
cavern with artificial light
no practitioner of black magic he's a
kind of natural scientist who splits his
time between the subterranean palace and
an observatory on mount carmel
where he watches
venus and mars without any veil
as well as the slow or rapid orbits of
the heavenly bodies he looks down on the
generation of the rain and dew and upon
how lightning is kindled and strikes the
earth
the science of the magus can be linked
to epicurean attitudes and it is he who
recounts to be sure with disapproval the
song of armeta's artificial siren who
advises
ronaldo to enjoy his body
let him carry nothing if the heavens
thunder or lightnings let it menace and
kindle bolts as much as it likes
such thunder and lightning an epicurean
would explain has nothing to do with the
gods
the meal and the sumptuous underground
palace of the magus recalls the banquets
of carthage and scaria
his establishment in the womb of the
earth is a scientific version
mediated through fracastoro's poem of
the fairy treasure vaults found in
previous italian heroic poems
riches science and technology come
together
in this projection of modernity
apparently far from the 11th century
world of the first crusade
so does the specter of a godless
materialism that tasso tries to put to
rest
the magus was born a pagan thought he
knew all that there was to know about
the workings of nature but then he met
peter the hermit who converted and
baptized him he is another man
imparte than the one he used to be and
watch out for that because that's what
pedrock says about himself the opening
of the kansas i'm another man
in parte
for what i used to be
and is the mega suitably enough given
his realm of medals who will play vulcan
and provide ronaldo with the epic shield
on which his estee ancestors are
depicted del sangue dazzio glorioso
augusto lordin vista video lulu in
toronto from the blood of the ost
glorious and august the order was seen
without interruption
by fortunate puns actium and augustus
viewed as the climax of virgil's
description of the shield of aeneas
begin the actresses of ronaldo's shield
if the episode like the models of homer
scaria and virgil's carthage affords a
glimpse of a seemingly post-epic
scientific modernity of the literally
earthly wealth and epicurean unbelief
it seeks preemptively to recruit that
future for the conservative religious
and heroic aims of tasso's poem
but it may succeed in doing so like the
conversion of the magus himself
only in
part now by contrast spencer's cave of
mammon in book two count of seven of the
fairy queen reduces this future
to a bourgeois world of money and in
doing so he demonizes the scarier
carthage episode drawing on the same
sources as tasso's episode of the magus
and on the episode itself
spencer first places the underground
treasure cave of mammon next door to
pluto's hell
activating the similarity of the names
of
excuse me of pluto and plutus the god of
wealth
and then shows it leading into hell
itself in the garden of proserpena and
the adjoining river cocidis
covered with smoke and suit mammon first
appears to quote have been seared in the
smith's fire spitting forge
and his realm contains a forge its
furnace's embellos manned by fiends
spencer associates its fires difficult
to distinguish from hellfire with vulcan
and earlier under his other virgilian
name with mulsiper this smithy does seem
to pro does not seem to produce any
hephestian artwork or weaponry just the
precious metals themselves with which
the money god earlier points out
gaian might buy
shields steeds and arms as well as
crowns and kingdoms
but it may have been produced it may
have produced a hephestian automata in
the allegorical figure of disdain a
giant made of gold in the 1590 fairy
queen of iron in its 1596 version who
dogs guy in steps ready to snatch and
destroy him
diane rise that
gaian replies
that he would rather gain kingdoms the
old-fashioned way
by the brute force of arms and an
appointed aristocratic threat against
this capitalist upstart asserts that he
would quote
be lord of those that [ __ ] have than
them to have myself and be their serval
slave
mammon looks like a member of the fugger
family and merchant bank which was a
fogger banking and merchant family
who monopolized mining and trade in
metals
mammon represents the new world of
capitalism and its urban middle class he
leads gaian into a throne room that is
long and wide as its some guild or
solemn temple were
that is the haunt of guildsmen and of
lawyers
the latter like arieosto's judge
on the throne is his daughter philotime
the lover of honor
who fuels ambition and is a kind of
alternative ego i'm sorry excuse me is a
kind of alternative or allegorical alter
ego of queen elizabeth
the bourgeoisie claims his own
independent realm within the heroic
world of the poem
the episode reveals its links to the
fiation carthage model at the level of
plot when mammon like elsinous offers
his daughter in marriage to the visiting
hero
gaian turns him down with a politeness
that's bordering on sarcasm
it would be too great a theologically
colored grace
conferred on him he says when of course
it would be he the gentleman who would
confer honor on the moneyed citizens
daughter he might marry
perhaps the honor her name says she
craves
so many elizabethan gentlemen did
replenishing their own family fortunes
in the process
nor will diane eat at the prophet the
prophet golden fruit nor sit down on
mammon's silver stool
there is not going to be any fiation or
carthaginian banquet in this episode
gaian just says no to all these
temptations of spencer's present and
signals the poem's aristocratic disdain
for the new money of the city
better than any allegorical giant
but mammon spells out that times have
changed
how that does live in later times must
wage thy works for wealth and life for
gold
engage he is the capitalist's future
that is already here and that threatens
to relegate the heroic world of
of fairyland to the past
from mama's point of view perspective
already available to spencer's first and
later readers these cracks in epic's
aristocratic facade are
easier to see and i simply can't really
resist this
spencer wickedly parodies guy in
centennials disdain from mammon's riches
and reduces it to braggadocio in the
words of braggadocio himself in the
ensuing welbecko helena fablio of books
of books three nine and ten
when malbeco miser and dublin of mammon
offers the imposter knight money in
order to enlist him in the recovery of
his runaway wife elenor
bragadocha replies
i
low i loathe as dung nadeem my due
reward fame is my need and glory
virtuous prey but minds of mortal men
are mutual marred and moved to miss with
massive mucks on meet regard
the over-the-top alliteration of the
final couplet gives the game away and
lowers still further the low comedy of
the episode braggadocio goes on to steal
malbeco's gold
as paradile has stolen and abandoned
malbeco's wife eleanor and these false
knights just might disclose the true
nature of knighthood
the episode further rewrites the earlier
mammon allegory through another version
of the phiatian carthaginian banquet
the meal that the unwilling host malbeco
is forced to offer the wandering knights
who otherwise to threaten to burn down
his castle
and at which paradile and britamart each
recount their trojan genealogies in the
manner of the guests odysseus and aeneas
eventually helena herself said small
becca's house enriches a fire like
another burning troy as spencer offers a
debased version of the ur epic myth of
troy
in a may december story of adultery out
of chaucer's merchant's tale and ghost
coins the adventures of fj novellas like
the ones told at the end of the orlando
freozo
or he reduces that myth the trojan myth
as the physician barred demonicus does
in the odyssey to the adultery of an
aphrodite and an aries at the expense of
a gold handling smith hephaestus
with little of the olympian fiation
sophistication good cheer
instead
spencer risks having the national
dynastic project troy novant gloriano
the fairy queen
the epicness of his poem swallowed up
into the mounted modern world and its
lower literary genres
malbeco turns into jealousy
the ethos particular to the novel
helen or helen [ __ ] ends up among the s
the seders that is
in satire
milton's eden
is the scarier of paradise lost while
pandemonium is the poem's malceverian
vulcanian rome
paradise law starts at the beginning of
time and treats events that shape us as
human beings it cannot but look forward
hegel notes in order to disqualify
paradise lost as an epic he says in
milton we always find feeling and
consideration drawn from a modern
imagination of the moral ideas of his
day
this modernity takes two forms utopian
and the scarier like eden which is not
primitive enough for hegel
demonic in satan's hephaestian capital
and seat of monarchy at once too at
avistic and all too actual
for for milton
milton gives us the epic coordinates of
eden in the menu
that eve gathers together for the
couple's first dinner party in honor of
the angel raphael the poem's version of
the epic banquet
whatever earth all-bearing mother yields
in india east or west or middle shore in
pontus or the punic coast or where
al-sinus reigned fruit of all kinds
the whole globe is contracting to eden
which boys between east and west takes
on the milieu of mediterranean epic of
pontic cultures of the argonautica of
valerius flakus of punic carthage and
obscuria the realm of valcinous
the foodstuffs announced the familiar
toepast of the hospitable meal
accompanied by storytelling what follows
rafael's two long narrations of the war
in heaven and the creation of god's new
universe correspond to the songs of
demonicus and yopus
told here in a reversal of epic
convention by the guest rather than the
host
the fiation model remains in place
in in the poem
um
satan's subsequent approach to eve
hearkens back to odysseus's first
encounter with gnostica
it cascary itself is a place of edenic
innocence
pious though they are
adam and eve lived the epicurean good
life
of the fiations unwar-like looking
forward to the nightly love-making that
caps their existence they listen with
fascination to raphael's narration of
the war in heaven that cast such epic
heroism into a quaint literary past made
ridiculous by satan's invention of
artillery yes artillery was there from
the beginning at least from the second
day of the heavenly battle to ruin the
individual heroics of epic
eden is also realm of scientific
enlightenment where adam and raphael can
engage in astronomical observation much
like tasos magus
yopus is here too
adam and eve thus live not only the
beginning of human existence but in a
post-feudal post-epic age
as frederick jameson baldly and
brilliantly puts it alongside the feudal
world of god in his court of satan and
his host adamus cooley of another
species the commoner the first bourgeois
that extraordinary mutation which is
middle-class man is destined as we know
today to be fruitful and to multiply and
to inherit the earth unquote
the trouble with quoting jamiston is
that
the
what surrounds it does not seem so good
uh satan first enters eden in simile as
a thief meant to unhoard the cash of
some rich burger
eden like other epic versions of
physician scaria is a utopian projection
of a modern world that has superseded
epoch's own heroic realm
the realm of war
it is milton's dream of a virtuous
bourgeoisie a bourgeoisie still unfallen
and thus not yet subject to the sardonic
tinge of jameson's description
in a significant revision of his models
milton makes this viation eden not the
region of unbelief but of true
individual faith the more so when it
becomes after the fall a spiritual
paradise within
as opposed to the worldly religion of
the state that and its enforcers of
conscience
for at the same time that god makes
another heaven for these new creatures
satan and his followers mammon and
mulsiper make their own imitation of
heaven in their infernal capital city of
pandemonium
they do so slightly after god has made
the new eden and theirs too is a version
of modernity
the first prototype of the seats of
rising and falling empires that will
strew the globe catalogued in book 11.
borrowed from spencer milton's fallen
angel mammon mines gold from the bowels
of hell
moss appears herpestus formerly the arc
multipurpose feastus sorry
formally the architect in heaven works
the metal into molds and builds the
palace
pandemonium resembles both dido's
carthage and its wealth and built in a
day as it is the military rome that was
carthage's mortal enemy the conflation
suggests the devils are their own worst
enemies and that this seat of empire 2
is doomed to fail
such capital cities you trevor ropers
argued by the unsustainable consumption
of their royal courts and by the expense
of their military establishments had
doomed the mercantile city states which
had been the cradle of the renaissance
and its humanism and led to the
revolutions of the mid 17th century the
english revolution most memorable among
them
in fact as shown in the debates in the
infernal council on book one mammon the
representative of the city bourgeoisie
hater of royal pomp and advocate of
peace would like to be left alone to
quote live to ourselves though in this
vast recess free
and to none accountable
blair hawksby points out that mammon
represents a double of the middle class
adam but a godless demonic one and he is
swept up willing or not not only into
the building of pandemonium but into
satan's project of war and imperialism
multiple repeal reappears in the visions
of the future that michael bestows on
adam themselves modeled on vulcan's
shield of aeneas and the aeneid and her
pestis his shield of achilles in the
iliad
in the third vision the unnamed tubal
kane whose name was traditionally seen
to be a variant of volcane
invents metal working
the daughters of this race of cane will
seduce the children of seth hear the two
peaceable and free
quote in the amorous net fast caught
they liked and each his liking chose
unquote
as milton blends the myth of pandora
originally an automaton created by
hephaestus vulcan with the other
hephaestian story of aries in aphrodite
the offspring of these ill-mated
marriages will be the warrior giants the
first epic heroes and imperial
conquerors in human history and the once
godly now made mammons will find it
possible quote to live secure
worldly or dissolute on what their lord
shall leave them to enjoy
unquote
paradise lost offers two versions of the
bourgeois future
one fiation and utopian that appears to
supersede the royal aristocratic order
and its epic fictions
and one in which that regressive warrior
order keeps returning as it had in the
restoration in england and in which a
moneyed middle class finds itself as the
beneficiary and silent accomplice of
satanic military-industrial
establishment
in this second version epoch and its
glorification of war never dies away
however much paradise loss may claim to
end the genre
we can ask which of these futures is our
own
and let me just conclude we can pose
this question here and in other epics i
have discussed because the epic world is
not quote an entirely finished thing not
only as an authentic event of the
distant past but also on its own terms
and by its own standards unquote it is
not quote impossible to change to
rethink or reevaluate anything in it
unquote
these words are baktens and they are
doubling down on hegel that is
influenced to by lukach's notion of the
roundedness of the epic that is homeric
world
unlike lukach and hegel bakhtin does not
romanticize this epic world as a place
where one could be at home everywhere
the land of unified consciousness
there is nothing living about this world
at all and more than the odyssey does in
the underworld of book 11 bach team
consigns the genre to a past that is not
only absolute but dead
bakhtin broadly assimilates in epic the
other high genres of classical antiquity
in the middle ages all of them to be
made obsolete by the novel
his claim is transparently false
as if any work of literature could wall
itself off from its readers and quote
not permit an individual point of view
or evaluation unquote it's based on a
mistaken conception
excuse me
excuse me it is it is based on a
mistaken conception of the suppression
of the heroic that we've seen built in
we've seen epic built into its fictions
both stinger
and the listener imminent in the epic
genre bakhtin writes are located at the
same time and on the same evaluative
plane but the represented world of the
heroes stands on an elderly different
and inaccessible time and value plane
separated by epic distance the pace the
space between them is filled with
national tradition
unquote
such tradition we are asked to believe
freezes the meaning of the epic world
and the deeds done within it as
something sacrosanct beyond criticism
and evaluation
but tradition does not do anything of
the sort
sacred books
and just as much perhaps even more than
great literature which sometimes
acquires something of the aura of the
sacred
are reinterpreted argued over reattached
to the present precisely because they
have something at stake in them
if one wishes to grant him the benefit
of the doubt and i'm not so inclined
bhaktine may be isolating a particular
reverential mode of reading conservative
of reading sorry that is conservative
and class bound in nature
versus the more open democratic ethos
that he ascribes to the novel
but epic from its homeric beginnings has
figured a post-heroic audience inside
the poems in dialogue with the heroes
themselves opening up a portal to the
future
starting with virgil and taken up by the
renaissance epic poets these moments of
contact with a more modern future
especially with more modern readers
measure the cut excuse me
measure the lateness of the poem to the
tradition of the genre and to its
celebration of martial prowess
in all of these cases i have suggested
this maternity is linked to material
wealth and technology to alternative
ways of producing human prosperity that
do not depend
or do not seem to depend on warfare
this modernity looks back into the epic
world and asks awkward questions about
the purposes of heroism itself
about the greed that is taken by for
granted by a belligerent feudal society
at the same time it proposes enlightened
scientific attitudes that question the
religious props of that society
through its glimpses into a future
dwelling side by side with the present
of the world of heroes epic
far from being sacrosanct depicts its
own de-sacralization
thank you
[Applause]
no i'm happy to take questions
can you hear me
i'd like to hear a bit more about how it
works in the iliad
this sort of crashing of uh prolepsis
versus stuck in the past
uh farther places there to be examined
i'm thinking here mostly of uh
of so much of
what virgil does on these the later epic
writers
is so uh so much of that is from the
odyssey the world of ships and the trade
and there are so many banquets in the
odyssey and i'm wondering how i was
especially wondering whether you got uh
you couldn't work menelaus banquet
banquet uh in there in sparta especially
since it has a kind of big mercantile
theme there as well uh
where you have a case of a traditional
heroic warrior who somehow seems to have
upgraded to a tradesman so
um
okay so we're talking about the odyssey
and not the iliad
you said the okay but i do have the
iliad question it's kind of lurking in
the background as well okay well yeah i
think that i mean
i think it's ilian who says that both um
that
that menelaus and odysseus looked like
murder they they looked like merchants
who were going from place to place
accumulating goods so there is some
sense in which menelaus is
i mean menelaus is uh
palace and which is
she says well maybe i'm the richest man
on earth maybe i'm not but you know it's
i'm i'm he's quite he's quite satisfied
with himself um there there is a
relationship between that passage surely
and the and the the physicians and
scaria yeah it is
that we already have some some sense
that that this is that the world to
which people are returning is a
different is just not a it's not as
heroic a world something could happen in
those 10 years where middle east has
been getting all of his riches
and i guess part of my question was also
the way that crashes egypt together with
uh
well in in virgil's uh in virgil's cart
that you you have a kind of crash of
egypt with phoenicia and so those two
banquets coming together in carthage
would be a nice
a nice thing yeah
okay
thank you so much um i just have a
question about
sorry yeah i just have a question about
your interpretation
of odysseus's reception of demoticus's
song
you mentioned this relationship between
the killing of the suitors
and the capture of aries and aphrodite
and
on the one hand
yes like it does seem like a contrast
between this like more primitive
reaction
and the use of
like
artisan manufactured bondage and also
the use of like social bonds legally
on the other hand i think maureen alden
argues this in a 2017 article
it seems as though odysseus in the
audience of demodicus's song
might be seeing
that hephaestus gets laughed at by the
other gods might be seeing that there's
no mention that he receives a financial
recompense
and we conclude the song just looking at
aphrodite taking a bath
like the gods who are looking at her
getting caught in the net and so i'm
just wondering if
even on the level of the internal
audience odysseus himself there's a way
in which this portrait of modernity is
pushing odysseus back posing a warning
that legal bonds aren't enough and he
has to kill the suitors
to preserve any sense of dignity
well i i i
the poem clearly takes takes the is on
the side of odysseus
so when he comes back and and kills
everybody the poem
poem is on his side it however one can
ask oneself whether the the story of
aries and aphrodite does not offer
a different way that these things could
happen and that you know
yeah if you want to if you if you if you
decide that you want to absolutely
that you have to kill people and and and
use violence at the end then you can
make you can make these objections to
the story and say well does how well
does
he's just really come out at the end of
this
but there does seem to be some sense
that okay
what more did you expect from aphrodite
anyway
uh and that that but it's also it's a
comic song for
it
for the fiations
whatever it is for odysseus maybe maybe
be something else but as far as the
fiations are concerned i think that they
they're laughing along with the gods and
they're laughing along you know
the the dirty joke of of um of of hermes
and apollo hermes says
hey tie me up tie me up i i you know as
long as you tie me up with aphrodite i'm
i'm fine and i think we're supposed to i
think we're supposed to feel that that
that's
their kind of song as opposed to the two
epic things on either side of it
um that
that's
that's my line
i guess
but it's a great question and it's also
i mean i
you're right the poem the i just the
poem finally takes the side of odysseus
that's not
hello thank you this is really
interesting even though i had to come in
slightly late
but um i was wondering if you were going
to extend um what you're doing beyond
milton if there's another
uh epic beyond that that you would like
to fit in to what you've been talking
about
i mean i think
alas that that
milton really does slightly close the
tradition um there is um
the crazy marinella's terrible poem the
enrico
which is
like it's actually pre-milton
does have an interesting moment where if
a character named sir cena
a little little cersei
uh but who's a kind of natural scientist
and
where some of some of these same topoi
are being redeployed um and you know but
it's a kind of footnote i think i i'm
not really sure where one goes aft after
after after milton we really do get the
novel
um and i'm not sure that there's that
that this particular topos
that i can i can trace much beyond it i
mean i haven't looked into it in any any
depths but i was thinking of omaros by
derek walcott yeah but i mean there is
there's not
i don't think we have i mean i i
i like omarosa i don't think that there
is a scene that
that gives us this kind of
correspondence
i mean certainly omrose is a meditation
on particularly on the relationship of
novel and epic
and about and about what what happens in
in in a modern the modern commercial
world and what whether there is any real
epic
left
uh that that certainly is part of part
of its pathos i think
yeah
thank you
chris
i know as in a courtroom you're never
supposed to ask a question you don't
know the answer to and i really don't
know the answer to this but i'm going to
ask it anyway
what does
veggio's
13th book
do
to the aeneid as a as an act of
reception
in your
in your terms
um
okay well i mean one of the things it it
clearly part of what that book is trying
to do is is is to dispel the idea that
the indeed closes as it does with an act
with a brutal act of violence and
revenge but rather ends with with
marriage and and a and a kind of
a kind of happy futurity
um
what it does it also it may say
something about
veggie's own
time
wanting
i i'm not sure i can speculate
that much further than that but that
it's clear it's part of it it's sense of
uh of wanting to get virgil off the hook
in some ways is part is part of what
it's responding to but it's also and
it's also trying to normalize it's
trying to say yeah this is really a
comic poem at the end which it
it's to take the one way to look at is
to take the odyssean structure
of the second part of the india
which and to say yes it really is all
about returning home and getting and and
unifying
not reuniting but finding but finding a
wife
and that that i mean that is after all
part of what is happening in the second
part of of of the poem
and here it just it's simply it let's
let's take the happy sequel i mean one
could think about um
i i'm trying to what is the novel that's
based on lavinia's point of view um but
it is that
yeah lavinia um
uh that it is it's uh it's something
like that of trying to trying to uh make
make the indeed
more palatable
for for
for the schoolboy audiences to whom one
assumes
well it does i guess
i mean yeah i mean i
i just i don't remember it quite well
enough to be able to give you the answer
you know
david um i was thinking of epec and
empire quite a lot as i was sitting here
because i used to
teach in the course i think it's now
called english 130 that used to be
called english 129 and read epic and
empire to help me
understand the books and i guess many of
the themes from african empire sort of
underlie what you said today but i
wonder if looking back
uh you know
is there anything you think
differently about than when you wrote
that or does this
cast any new light on the work you did
then well thank you for that because i
mean yeah i mean
what i might have said in the intro in
my introductory remarks to this to this
already overly long uh lecture
uh was that this is it is a kind of we
think i mean
it's trying to look at epic from a
slightly different point of view than
than uh than epic
then the essay that begins epic and
empire which was again one of these sort
of big overview essays
and where i mean i do think
i mean i think it's clearly
uh
it celebrates a martial ethos and and a
a particular a particular class ethos
but that already from its very
beginnings it is telling you that there
are other possibilities and it projects
and i might what interests me is this
projection to a better into a different
future and maybe a better future
um which i think um
which has among other things women are
in charge um
they're i mean therefore it's totally
utopian uh that it is uh that that that
it's
materially
um
and technologically uh much more much
advanced and much more comfortable
and and much much less
uh given to war
and i think that one of the things that
interests me about the way that milton
may close this tradition is that he that
there's a certain despair about this he
gives you two different versions but
basically we seem to be living under the
satanic regime and not under the eudenic
one
good thanks
thanks so much david this was just such
a joy um
uh and maybe i'm just bringing out what
was implicit in the talk and
what i found so delightful but the idea
that epic has
encoded in it
tropologically uh sort of scenes of its
own reception
and i guess i'm wondering and again
going to do the thing where i ask a
question to which i don't know the
answer so much of this seems like um a
literary
history of epic in that you know are
these scenes of reading in particular or
you know how do you account for this
originating in an oral
form
what would i mean perhaps that actually
makes more sense at the scene of
hospitality being the kind of primary
scene of reception
um
thank you
kathy yeah i mean
the
we we assume that
the homeric poems were recited at
at events very much like the banquet in
scaria that you have a bank i mean and
they're famous for the opening of book
nine
this is what plato hated
odysseus says the best of things the
very best of things is when people all
sit here and and are eating and feasting
and listening to poetry
um and um so it is giving us it it is
clearly a scene of reception that's
already there in the in the archaic
world
by the time we get to virgil
i mean we're
probably people are listening to epic in
very much the same way that they're
probably these are probably it's being
recited orally
probably two to
people and and
maybe after dinner uh
and
but it is this we we are sort of seeing
and i think this continues all the way
all the way to through paradise lost
that these that raphael raphael's
telling his narrations
uh that this is this is one of the ways
in which
poetry that this long oral tradition is
still there because retirement people
read things loud
um in the
up until
up until audio books
but but but peop that
the knights
one way to understand
things like these in terminal 17
interminable 17th century novels
and um and very long 19th century novels
is that
you know every night after dinner
people are gathered together and
somebody's sitting there reading and
that this is very much a part of what
sociability was they didn't have
television
and so this is one this was one of the
ways in which these novels are are being
produced
what interests me is the notion i mean
clearly this talk said it is that this
it's always if the audience is projected
as being a future it's a posterity it's
a future audience
that's being this being imagined
and also one that basically is at
considerable distance from
this from the world of the of the of the
of the epic the epic can imagine
people who don't really share
some of its heroes values
and
right there
um
i mean the
i guess the corresponding moment in the
iliad is when when we find achilles
singing the the
the feats of heroes
uh in his tent that this is
that that's how this stuff is is being
is being transmitted
so
yes
maybe i'll take us to the final question
but david i want to ask you to maybe
reflect about what is the consequence
for a kind of longer literary history of
the talk you just gave because in part
what you're talking about is a kind of
dialectical relationship between a
mercantile commercial world of the
modern uh and
thinking of octavius and is anthony and
cleopatra the universal landlord
versus the epic past which is anthony
who will you know be defeated at actium
um and and i wonder if there's something
about the dialectical nature of these in
epic the way in which epic opens these
wormholes that might make us think or
rethink the kind of baktinian and
lucacian difference between epic and
novel to think about at what points does
the novel perhaps into the 19th and 20th
century even now
in its engagement with this dialectic
with this presentation of the kind of
future tense that is also retrospective
is returning us to some of the kind of
intellectual work that epic is doing and
the kind of cultural place that epic has
even if it's abandoning the specific
tropological tracing uh that you did in
this talk
well
it's a huge question to which i'm not
sure i can give a particularly
satisfactory answer but what i am trying
you know yeah i mean part of what i'm
clearly trying to say that
is
that
the bactenia model is that that the
novel swallows up all
genres
the meridian model is that the epic
swallows up all genres
uh and that it's already that and one
way to see this is that the
that
we already have novellas in in in some
ways included within
with with with with particularly within
renaissance epic but even
well let's take the arias and aphrodite
uh episode it's just that there are
generic mixings that are already there
in epic
um
yes i think that um
the
the question
of
where does the mercantile world fit
into
in
next it is it is literally adjacent in
the odyssey
to the uh to the world of the heroes and
the second part of the of the odyssey
the the stories of the phoenician
traitors are are all
and also of cretins who are also
seafaring people
um are are all over the place and they
they you know odysseus makes up stories
in which
he's interacting with with the
phoenicians with cretans
he's
and
we recognize that there is this whole
other world of trade and commerce
that's that's that's sitting there but
which is
which
is not being ennobled
uh through warfare
and
that is that that seems to me what it
means it is a dialectic that's there
from the beginning and if you want to
say that that is part of what the work
of the novel as a bourgeois particularly
as a bourgeois form is that perhaps it
does reverse these things part of the
problem also with bhaktine just to just
spell it out is that when bhaktine tries
to talk about
the novel partly because of
his own
his own political situation whatever he
wants to talk about the novel as being
something that comes from the folk from
down below and the novels of bourgeois
form and that's i mean lukach actually
has no problems with us but it's a but
it is it's a bourgeois form and
therefore it is trying to justify the
existence of a class that is not
aristocratic and noble even though many
of it many of its uh many of his
protagonists will still be from the old
aristocracy
so
i'm not sure i'm i'm rambling at this
point but i am but i i am but i think
that one way to look at this is a
certain kind of reversal that epic is
still looking at things to a certain
extent from the from the side of the of
the the dominant martial
ethos
and that
up to milton
where there's this where the reversal
really does take place
um and that the novel tends to
tends to follow milton and wishing to to
find a virtuous bourgeoisie
thank you so much david
i mean speaking of
of the dialectic i was thinking that
maybe um
lugar's point is not even so much
a distinction between a roundedness of
the apex
and something else in the in the novel
uh on the contrary one could say
nothing is more obsessed with
another version of roundedness than the
totality than the novel for for luke
couch uh it seems rather that
whatever he really
had to say about the epics his idea was
that
the epic had a ground
beyond or before itself
what is really epic for him is not so
much the ethics but the epic world the
world in which the epic originates as
the epic and the novel is
that totality which doesn't have an epic
world yeah
just one one last point of this uh i
mean luca wrote this piece
as a preface to a book he has never
written on dostoevsky and he was his
idea was a return of the
of kind of an epic constellation in
modernity so my question would be do you
think that this
brings something to
the possibility of
a literal history of the epics
well
okay i mean this the
i mean luke koch is
writing in a hegelian tradition
um and
hegel
in the aesthetics says that really there
are like four epics that actually are
epics they're the homeric poems he's not
quite sure about the odyssey but the
homeric poems
the mahabharata
the ramayana i'm sorry five
and and the sid those are the those are
the four and
by which you and
excuse me for saturn
and because germany needs an epic maybe
the knee belongingly
um
but that's it
so epic is very narrowly defined
as being the and and
also for hegel it's the primitiveness of
homer which is which is all important to
the world and also the idea is hegel
knows that the person who wrote
composed excuse me composed the homeric
poems is from a later period
but this person seems to have managed to
completely absorb himself back into this
early heroic period
and therefore he is and therefore he and
his characters feel absolutely no kind
of
questioning or disconnection with the
world in which they live
um
well this becomes a problem when you
start reading the iliad and the first
person you meet is achilles who's
profoundly um
you know disconnected with his community
and with the world
um around him so that but this is a kind
of romantic romantic world that is
imagined by hegel and that to a very
large extent lukacs repeats in the
opening of the theory of the novel and
that the hero is that it's where
everyone is at home in the world
um where there's no
dissociation of sensibility to use to
use uh elliot's term but i mean that's
just i mean
it's clearly not right about these poems
and it is part of it's part of a certain
kind of romantic nostalgia which is not
on which is partly a nostalgia for the
austrian regime
even by people who were probably
supporters of the french revolution but
nonetheless
have a kind of deep nostalgia for this
and that's where a certain kind of
romantic primitivism
comes in
um
but
it seems this is just not you know when
one reads the poems this is simply uh
not the case it's nice for theory but
theory is you know when you
that actually look at the poems they
don't they don't work that way
um so that i think one way to just is
that the notion of roundedness and of of
well more of being at home in in the
heroic world is what is what
hegel um publishes and and again it's
it's probably also nostalgia for faith
nostalgia for for the in the imminence
of of of the of the divine in the world
um
it's already
called into question by epic from its
beginning
and that and i just think that that's
what one had one has to just sort of see
that that
in in that way human nature did not
change
in the way that that um
that literally that this version of
literary history would want to make us
think
thanks
to our reception in phelps hall which is
on the fourth floor but please join me
in thanking david for a fantastic
you